- Des baraques en préfabriqué
à perte de vue... Le camprararap
de réfugiés syriens au monde,
est devenu en 10 ans une ville
semi-permanente où la survie
"Voice e e e logement",
nous dit Waheeb Alali.
Il nous présente Khal 6 6 6 6 e
du diabète, et le benjamin de
la fraterie, Mohamed, 6 mois.
Les trois fils de Waheeb
grandiront probablement
derrièreururururs.
"Je suis réfugié dans ce camp
depuis huit ans, j'avais 19 ans,
une réponse du Canadaà ma deman"
Waheeb n'a pas pu poursuivre
ses étud
ne lui permet pas de travailler.
Et comme si ce n'était p
assez, il doit prendre en charge
sa famille et ses deux parents.
Sa mère a subi un accident
vasculaire cérébral il y a
quelques jours : elle est
pour la soigner, il faudraitoror
des frais médicaux et de
physiothérapunununununununununu.
"Attendre ne serait-ce
est insoutenable! Je veux offrir
une meilleure vie à ma famille,
à mon fils diabétique,
Cette incompréhension
est partagée par Khalil,
KHALIL ALALI, frère de Waheeb- t
correct, tout est correct;
il n'y
qui manque, tout est beau
mais on attend.
Il y a cinq ans, l'ambassadedudt
offert de se réinstaller
au pay
- Quand j'ai reçu cet appel,
j'ai vu une petite l
dans le noir.
- La famille s'est é
à Saint-Constant et s'est même
agrandie avec la naissance
Tous sont citoyens canadiens.
OLA ALALI, conjointe de Khalil
- On dit merci Canada
C'est beaucoup pour nous.
- Quand on est arrivés,
on a commencé à zéro, zéro,
zéro maison, zéro amis, f f f fé
à- - - - - - - - - - - - - - - ,
Khalil travaille à temps
et il a même acheté une maison
à crédit.s s s s s s s s s s s e
cette prospérité avec le res
de la famille.
- Mon père, ma mère, ils vont
chez nous; mais mon frère
et sa famille, pour eux,
on va louer un appartement.
on a acheté tous les meubles.
-
- Tout ce processus de
parrainage a été prir r r r r re
de citoyens canadiens,
des résidents de Hemmingford.
Il y a cinq mois, ils ont enfin
un message du ministère deImImIr
annonçant l'arrivée possible
de
leur demandant de soumettre
un plan de quarant
Depuis, ils n'ont plus
de nouvelles.UCUCUCUCUCUCUCUCUCD
- Ce qu'on reçoit comme réponse,
c'est : si, , , , , , , , , , ,e
encore plus de temps. Ç
gênant, c'est carrément gênant.
EVELYNE BOUCHARD
enfants, ça peut pas être plus
innocent que ça. Il me semble
que c'est la moindre des choses.
JONATHAN MUNRO-JONES
- Les membres de la communauté,
tout partout à Hemmingford
puis dans les esesesesesesesesee
qu'ils vont arriver? Comment va
votre projet? Ça fait longtemps.
Est-ce que c'est à cause
- Le ministère de l'Immigration
nous assure que le Canada
d'offrir une protection à ceuxqn
offrant un refuge aux personnes
Au 31 mars 2022,
16 365 dossier
syriens sont en cours
de traitement; les délais
de 28 à 35 mois.
Alali a commencé en 2018.
Ce processus est assez long
et il est difficile d'obtenir
cette avocate.
Me p p p p p p p p p p prés. Aso
Avocats en droit d'immigration
- On devrait fairet-t-t-t-t-t-te
plus d'efforts et de moyens pour
faire venir ces personnes-là
parce qu'on le sait très bien,
ils vont contribuer, ils vontr e
continue. Mais tout délai,
tos's's's's's's's's's's's's's'ss
impacts dans leur
- Khalil et son épouse
s'éléléléléléléléléléléléléphons
et aux rares photos de
leur famille dans
Pour les épauler dans
cette succession d'épreuves, les
membres du groupe de parrainage
DAVID SMITHlalalalalalalalalalae
Alali, cette histoire-là est
représucucucucucucucucucucucucu,
nettement plus importa
il faut vraiment qu'on règle,
qu'on répare le système.
- L'arrivée de la famille Alali
qu'une question de temps, maisce
cruellemen